your wife doesn't believe i'm live oh
shout out to your wife
i think i'm live but
sometimes it's hard to believe reality
oh no my wife grow a beard
oh your cat doesn't believe i'm live
do cats have beliefs i think i was gonna
play
um this mysterious challenge
every time i play hari krishna it's
hari krishnan i should say uh it's from
position
oh yakshimash i hope that's a polite
greeting
oh
we just can't even count all the bishops
they just go off the
frame what is this
star etta i'm going to russia russia
soon so i have to
be speaking some russian straw
atta means what is this
and shtokoi i think is what is wrong
might be wrong about that though i'm
white am i winning
no but maybe oh i might be winning
wait
so all i need to do is bring my king
here and my bishop here and it's
mate but that might be hard to force
let's start with check
this is actually a cool position so
king has to move here and then i'll play
bishop e7
okay so i'm restricting the king
like this
it looks confusing but basically
i only i only can play on half the board
so i'm saving half of my energy
i can only play on the dark squares
and now the plan is to walk the king
here get opposition
i have a feeling white's winning here
that's crazy if white is actually mating
by force
i'm just not entirely sure how i'm gonna
so i might have to put black and
zugswang somehow
okay now i'm threatening this
wow how to do this i have this move
i might be winning in just a few more
moves
wait a minute
and it's so hard to round my mind around
this
the the number of bishops just hurt my
eyes
ah
okay so i'm threading made in three
so my king needs to be here but i can't
allow black to prevent me
yeah it's like one of those um like
rubik's cube things
but not a rubik's cube
i don't know what this is like
check let's check first
and i'll play this
there's no pawns and there's no
there's really no possible captures so
i'm racing against the 50 move rule
okay again i'm now i'm threatening made
in two
block only has one move
so i have to conceptualize like how do i
how do i win this i feel like i force
the king to where i want it
if i move i can move this way
okay so i need to either get my king
here here
which would require
maybe i have to force the king more to
the center
but how do i chew that even
is this winnable okay
there's this idea to then check
doesn't do much though
check
oh i have an idea
okay i have an idea to bring my king
here
not sure if this works but let's try it
thank you xmar
lacks and blunderprone
oh extension was until may 2022 i
appreciate that
so i'll have to keep streaming at least
until then
probably beyond then
if i zoom out will show the number of
bishops
there we go plus what is this word
plus something is that 90
plus yeah probably plus 90
because there is 64 squares on a
chessboard so that means there's
31 bishops 31 times
3 is 93 and then yeah that's plus 90.
okay
okay
it's funny that you can be up 90 points
of material
and almost losing hopefully losing
check
okay obviously king here and then
how to do this
it's kind of frustrating
oh okay now i play i can move my bishop
anywhere
let's play here
so now i'm threatening okay threatening
made into a king here and then mate
so the king can't move back it has to
move this way
and then i'll play this move
i think i'm making progress so king b6
let's try and calculate mate bishop e3
king
a5 bishop c5 and then the king's
completely stuck
i have to walk my king in probably here
or maybe i play this first
no i need my king here though
okay i'm i'm repeating we'll see what uh
oh no wow ah i missed king c7
oh i wasn't thinking i was expecting
king v6 immediately
what was i doing okay
what in the bishop i saw it too
i just got confused
wait am i winning now
it's still winning
it's still winning because chuck here
here it's winning
good evening here it's winning here here
it's so i have opposition
is that all i needed the whole time is
opposition
yeah i guess once white gets opposition
it's winning
except here
oh i missed i missed an easy win i could
have just
maneuvered okay
it's winning though
it's one of okay i know what this
reminds me of
it's that optical illusion illusion
where you see the
um imaginary squares
let's go okay let's do it
i took the the harder around
so i could have won much more easily
um so in this position yeah it's just
made in four
so i got my king here all i needed to do
was uh
keep the opposition but force this in
this
and the way to do that was just to
maneuver my bishop
to this diagonal
and it's winning that made my head hurt
this also makes your head hurt kind of
hard to calculate mate when there's just
so many bishops
okay at least i feel accomplished though
i'll probably put that on youtube
i'm curious how many people managed to
figure this out
quicker than me so if we go back
wow it's made in 31 from this position
no i feel like this position just breaks
stockfish
it says made in 31 but it also says
the steering position is made in 11.
oh we can't ask table base
i made one blunder this game
okay sockfish has a hard time finding it
because uh
it's low depth but eventually it finds
it
so that's cool
okay that will go on youtube uh thanks
hari krishnan for the challenge
i was uh yeah i don't train for
positions like this
where'd you even find positions like
this move five i missed made in one
no did i
i missed maiden one on move five oh no
what did i play ah it's made in one
oh no